[Music]
just who is that grey-skinned figure who
wants to kill gods is there any
significance to the statues behind jane
of course there is keep watching for
these easily missed details on the
second thor love and thunder trailer and
more the god of thunders and ability to
sub thanos in avengers infinity war took
a toll on his mental health during the
five-year gap in endgame he gained
weight and remained indoors away from
the bustle of new asgard in thor love
and thunder we'll see how the odin son
undergoes another physical
transformation the first love and
thunder trailer offered a quick look at
thor getting back into shape fans see
more of this training montage in the
second which reveals another element of
his exercise regimen resistance training
one of his exercises appears to be
pulling the guardians of the galaxy's
ship the beneath as it flies in the
opposite direction love and thunder
seems to predominantly show off a more
chiseled thor so it stands to reason
that his workout regimen won't take up
much of the film's run time still it's a
welcome inclusion
throughout the trailer thor is decked
out in a bright golden and blue suit of
armor with a red cape at one point he
also wears a very ornate helmet that
covers his face mcu fans definitely
haven't seen thor sport duds as regal
and colourful in previous movies but
comics readers were likely squealing in
delight as he appears to be wearing a
pretty accurate recreation of his comics
universe battle armor as nerdist points
out the first time marvel fans see him
where the armor is in 1987's thor issue
378 by writer walt simonsen and artist
salva semmer in the story thor designs
the outfit himself after hella curses
him to become mortal making his bones
fragile as paper tony stark forges a
battle toughened casper thor when he
breaks his arm during a fight and the
god of thunder subsequently creates a
suit that's impervious to harm
thor's estrangement from former romantic
partner jane foster has been a sore spot
for him you can tell because he
sheepishly recites the exact amount of
time he has been separated from her once
they reconnect following her debut as
mighty thor what's a family three four
years
eight years seven months and six days
give or take portman's last major
appearance in the marvel cinematic
universe came in 2013's thor the dark
world although she was briefly in
avengers end game via reused dark world
footage mcu fans have known portman was
set to return to the thor series ever
since her role was announced at san
diego comic-con 2019. given the extreme
precision of his response about how long
it's been he appears more infatuated
with jane than ever before in another
scene thor congratulates jane on her
battle prowess there's also a quick
moment where two forearm guard clad
warriors and capes appear to embrace
pinky fingers seems these two could
become an item once more
the love and thunder teaser didn't offer
any clear looks at christian bale as the
film's big bad gore the god butcher we
got a few in this trailer though he's
shown wearing simple white robes and
occupying a spooky black and white
locale that may just be the necroverse
gore reveals himself to be soft-spoken
methodical and more than a little scary
oh god she will die gore is a relatively
new character to comics readers debuting
in 2012's thor god of thunder issue 2.
he was a pious man but following the
demise of his family he began to
question the existence of his own god
and became enraged at gods in general
when he encounters two deities in battle
he kills one using all black the
necrosword beginning his universe-wide
crusade against all gods a quick shot
shows a winged horse descending from the
sky tessa thompson's valkyrie is set to
feature prominently in the movie so it's
quite possible we've seen this horse
before in one memorable ragnarok
flashback scene valkyrie rides one of
these valkyrie steeds into battle
against heller and we learn all but one
were wiped out during that doomed attack
during the final battle in avengers end
game valkyrie emerges from a portal
riding the last surviving valkyrie seed
into battle against thanos the steed in
the love and thunder trailer seems to be
the same one since valkyrie is now the
king of new asgard it's only right that
she has a stallion fit for royalty the
steed features prominently on the new
poster for love and thunder as well
making it likely we'll see a lot of king
valkyrie's trusty mount
in one very cool shot jane foster's
mighty thor summons lightning as she
stands in a mysterious hall with large
golden busts against the wall this hall
must be important because those statues
depict some of the biggest characters in
all of marvel comics on the front right
we see the living tribunal this
multiverse guardian has been around
since the beginning of time and has
three heads it serves to keep cosmic
balance behind the living tribunal is
the watcher who what if viewers should
know well the watchers are a race of
beings so this could be any of them but
there's a good chance as uwatu the
watcher of earth616 on the left in front
is death in her skeletal form she's
pretty self-explanatory in the comics
death is who thanos wanted to impress by
using the infinity gauntlet to wipe out
half of the universe's population though
the movies obviously changed that story
detail behind death is a statue that is
a little hard to make out but it could
represent eon yet another cosmic entity
that embodies time in the very back
appears to be infinity yes another
cosmic entity who represents all of
space and creation
in the newest saw love and thunder
trailer fans finally get to hear russell
crowe's mcu version of zeus speak after
only seeing him from behind in the
teaser let's see who you are and take
off your disguise but that would be a
big deal by itself but then the greek
god uses his awesome divine powers to
magically flick off thor's clothes talk
about fan service it's encouraging that
writer director taika waititi is keeping
the same brand of humor that he brought
to thor ragnarok little moments like
this go a long way especially when
contrasted with the darker stuff
involving gore and his mission to kill
every god plus it gives fans a peek as
how other deities fit into the mcu at
least until gore gets his hands on them
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the mcu are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]
you